hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin
relativ großer pokémon fernen das merkt
man beispielsweise daran gibt es jeden
fall spielen wir heute pokemon auf dem
pc allerdings pokémon 3d ich hab noch
keinen spielstand das heißt wir klicken
einfach mal aufs spiel
da ist doch schon gleich professor wie
heißt er nochmal meine ist auch bekommen
mikrogramm froh dass wollte es im happy
day tipp bei create creature boxer
namens luca ja mein name ist luca luka
bin ich ja und pokémon story für gauck
ich glaube es geht nur um mein gott es
ist viel besser als ich es mir
vorgestellt hab' ich verstehe zwar die
steuerung nicht so ganz aber sonst ist
eigentlich alles gut die steuerung ist
eventuell ein bisschen schwammig also
ich kann so ganz normal rumlaufen
allerdings wenn ich einfach mal es
drücke dreht er sich einfach einmal im
kreis ich drück es hier drückt sich
einfach ich fühle mich gerade wie in so
einem shooter oder so dass ich hier alle
habe ich nicht auch theoretisch auf den
computer zugreifen da wieder deuce
diese ganzen leute haben das spiel
unterstützt und zwar des echten cooles
projekt allerdings dass aller coolste
daran ist eigentlich der online
meine mama ist er pixelig der online
modus kann ich gerade nicht zocken weil
ich davon irgendwie keinen spielstand
habe also ich warte ein friseur sieht
man dass ich weiß es ist mal wieder zu
kurz lukrativ namens number das war die
bedingung als ich mein handy bekommen
hab ich kann hier fernsehen schauen und
kann hierdurch durch stühle durchlaufen
hier ist unsere küche so ganz normales
pokémon ash ketchum haus und jetzt
lokalpresse rahmen des camps am new
pokémon luca ich dachte gerade ich
könnte wirklich so cool rumlaufen aber
es ist wirklich so ich kann mich nur
zwischen diesen fugen hier quasi bewegen
aber es ist auch schon megacool also wir
gehen mal ich versuche einfach ins hohe
gras zu gehen weil ich glaube bei den
pokémon übrigens ich muss man nicht
zuende räten ich kann nicht online
spielen das spiel ist eigentlich dafür
ausgelegt online zu zocken mit passender
zeit zeit passt echt gerade weil es ist
gerade dunkel aber halt online mit
freunden und zum skate luca der moment
ist gekommen den ich mir ein pokémon
aussuchen darf ich nehme einfach
jetzt weiß ich auch welche edition das
ist möchte feurige jährige luca risso
schätze ich an den urin kalkreiniger als
klar es gibt einen das feurige um
aufkommen ok und freunde taktvoll nicht
in akinator fragen alles klar als er als
klar ja wirklich alles klar presse dann
gehen wir doch jetzt mal ab infografik
wieso spricht das spaß dann ab geht's
raus ins wilde gras sei hier neuburg ja
so schön und jetzt kommen wir endlich da
hin wo ich schon endlich in kommen
wollte weil hier denke ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich ja der macht jetzt den
pokémon serie
ich könnte tatsächlich meinen zweiten
wahlrecht eigentlich ganz cool es ist
nicht dieses normale scheiß pokémon ist
nicht scheiße luca aber es ist also
pokémon in 3d und das ist halt übels
nein mein gott ich bin überrascht was
können jetzt nur vögel verfolgt mich die
ganze zeit das steuerkreuz erinnert mich
ein bisschen an minecraft ohne das kann
ich ja nur mit verschneider machen
sollte sich mal eben hier rüber als ob
ich sogar mit bären klappt in dieser
scheiß version junge wie geil ist das
denn komme ich spreche jetzt mal einfach
diesen typen jahr an damit ich euch mal
zeigen wie das aussieht wenn man hier
kämen beruhigen
ich wollte gerade gegen dich kämpfen ich
will dass wir nicht wieder so lange
halten weil ich nicht so viel zeit
abzuschneiden gerade ehrlich gesagt ich
möchte einfach ein kampf zeigen möchte
zeigen wie cool diese 3d kämpfe sind bei
regel dass man mit irgendwie kämpfen
aber da schaut euch an wie cool way
through the beard das ist
wie heißt es noch auf deutsch ich glaub
das heißt einfach hohe oder gar von
ricoh und jetzt wie nice das aussieht
das ist einfach geil gemacht so kommt
man jetzt mal tackle das ist ja auch so
typisch pokemon welcher dummkopf nützt
diese andere attacke am partner fallen
was haben die immer irgendwie theke und
häuser oder tackle und silberblick oder
sowas vor jakub doch das ist es nämlich
aus identified war
jetzt hast du eine bessere trefferquote
aber du bist eh gleich tod von gainey
vor experience points okay okay das war
quasi der erste kampf dem ich irgendwie
werden welche richtung müssen wir ich
laufe jetzt einfach mal hier gerade so
als ob jetzt noch ein kampf kommt wir
versuchen das jetzt mal einfach zu
fangen
falls die poker bälle haben keine quelle
es tut mir leid aber muss ich dich
leider besiegen ich glaube da hinten ist
sogar tatsächlich schon die nächste
stadt können wir ihnen wie schneller
laufen wo es vorher hatte ich mit der
rechten
joachim trainer ich bin kein rookie
trainer nein du brauchst mir nichts
beibringen auch jetzt bringt mir das
spaß trotzdem irgendwas bei und ich muss
dem camp ackermann da die vorkommen
feiern bevor dieser dummkopf und sind
noch viel länger alles möglich erklärt
was wir schon wissen freunde das war's
mit pokémon teil eins ich weiß nicht
wollt ihr den zweiten part ich will
eigentlich nicht weiß was ein pokémon
markt ist ich wollte das ganze
eigentlich nur so als ein video aufbauen
so wie ich das von anderen indie spielen
mache auch ja danke dass das gute 30 ist
ich wollte das ganze also ein kleines
video auf von wo ich euch kurzzeitiger
es gibt pokémon 3d und das so ein
bisschen zu zeigen so bauch voll cool
haye kann sein dass da die see ist alles
klar
jedenfalls hat mir echt tatsächlich spaß
macht man kann den schritt tatsächlich
sogar speichern deswegen wenn ihr
vielleicht noch mal ein zweiter teil
sehen wollt schreibt in die kommentare
oder mit schaue ich mal vielleicht mal
ja kein zweiter nicht noch mal lust
drauf habe aber es hat mir tatsächlich
spaß macht dankeschön das mit zeigt das
ist ein haus ist